I think a lot of people maybe go through
life without really noticing all of the
things that go around them and of course
for us we are very aware of the world
around us and I think we learn from it
and think of how we can make the world a
better place the magical thing about
course 4 is it really teaches you how to
take your creativity and your design
ideas and then translate them into
physical realities that are spatial
occupiable inhabitable and have a kind
of powerful cultural resonance
I think that all of these different
interests come together in the studio
environment that's really where all of
our different ideas really get to take
form just about all our studios have a
lot of freedom and our ability to design
our own projects and really take our own
ideas as far as we can you see other
people's projects and you're like how
did they come up with that like how does
that mind come up with something that
cool it's a costume for the Galactic
Olympics
it's basically supposed to connect every
part of your body the goal is to develop
new star school systems using small
diner around timbre we're currently on
the side of the Collier Memorial a
structure that is being built in Sean
Colliers honor it makes a concept of the
project is that it stands as a
long-lasting monument this speaks to the
strength of our community and we
designed it to work in compression as a
series of stunts held in place only by
gravity as an undergrad we're on the UC
like
but actually blowing it up into a real
scale where people can actually pass by
and inhabit the space it's just a really
I specifically really liked the
experience of design reviews going in
front of a group of people and having to
present your work and understanding that
that's just part of the process and it
can get better and can build course for
gave me the opportunity to work in a
professional environment and work
alongside extremely talented and
motivated people you work so close with
faculty you talk so much with professors
you learn something you can never learn
from just taking on class like Professor
learn from you you learn from professors
there are civil engineers and there are
mechanical engineers and their material
scientists and architecture majors and
everyone plays a role it makes a lot
more sense because architecture is a lot
more interdisciplinary than people
expect so cool to get to work with
designers and engineers at the same time
and I think that really validates the
word
one of the things that I really liked
about MIT was that I was exposed to all
different types of feel it's really a
great cross-pollination of disciplines
that I think led to what I do now course
war brings together architects designers
artists historians and engineers around
ideas and concepts to transform how we
imagine and construct our environment
but always thought that the architecture
department teaches you how to solve
problems and it's a way of thinking it
lets you approach the honoree
there is an incredible amount of support
it's almost like an expectation that you
can immediately try to make an impact I
think that's the really exciting part is
that there's really it's not just about
kind of working abstractly it's really
about immediately applying what you're
learning to try to make the world a
better place
you
you